go to the top of your neon sign alright
let's do it
yay oh hello 9 the gas helps me run
insanely fast Oh what the hell
alright curious this is a new thing
all right you're lazy neon gas go make
yourself useful
but hedg gay huh so what is this dude
what does he let us do I want to see I'm
curious collect all the lumens
oh so it's kind of like when we
destroyed those goddamn forsaken
vehicles all over I right fetch
go fetch those firepower sorry I feel
bad every time but I just is that all of
them yep
oh my god is that thing from beyond 2
souls buck is he talking about
alright and start this race i haul ass
what the [ __ ] wasn't there dinosaurs
here before i swear to god that was
dinosaurs he whoa Shan ik yeah this is
amazing gotcha back yeah yeah I need to
do these races to upgrade myself
interesting hello a Korean is that like
a friendly way to call them Russians
defeating enemies below a native
especially Hank alright Oh
whoa take that at Koreans
I mean asshat occurrence wow they're
really good at exiting cars at the same
time once you defeat enough enemies you
can trigger a neon singularity all right
it's time occurrence oh hello Oh goodbye
I mean sorry about that occurrence nice
yoga pants occurrence free the neon we
did it don't order bar me man can we
actually get up this way holy [ __ ] oh
god oh god nevermind nevermind
alright alright alright alright ah it's
so hard
barrel what are you doing here [ __ ] you
it's what you get oh yeah I'm so sorry
oh no he thought it was so funny he's
like dying laughing yeah ha ha that
barrel oh I got a [ __ ] funny oh my god
I'm dying
I'm literally dying someone kill me
please someone please have mercy
hey thank you others graffitis as well
young graffiti oh yeah she used to do
those yeah move the controller and whoa
whoa I know why I'm supposed to shoot oh
okay got it
there we go like a bird like I don't
know where my neon is I don't know why
yeah a baby and I give it to you I'm
like sonic I was strange hey I don't
know where my shoes is I don't know
where my shot oh yeah baby I'm like did
they kill ya
I'm glad they ditch your the whole DUP
it car destroying way of getting
upgrades it was really really not that
fun to keep doing over and over here we
go yes that is how people talk to each
other
come on you have a conduit underside
there host will get these guns to young
men and they'll use them to find grits
we're good nice driving by the way not
your guns are a mare everybody how are
they dare to fight against me oh [ __ ] I
carry it is awesome are they now come on
that Korean I thought you knew better
don't you know the power of gnosis the
greatest sniper flying after
yeah that's what get you boys armed and
out looking for prints or always a hole
in your sack yes but stole stealing from
the enemy tell you men I'll protect
anyone out looking for Brits
damn girl what is she doing oh alright
so I control yeah there we go really
that's all I gotta do what the hell I
don't just click the button thought I
would actually do [ __ ] let's find your
weakness let's your weakness your leg
Sarah Pauling with it well there is now
I asked the problem is like - what the
hell let's get some speed whoa nailed it
new mission growth a mission alright now
I guess I press the down button oh wait
I don't have enough [ __ ] alright why do
we trust this guy again I don't know man
I'm just slowly fabulae seing this world
to become more pink and beautiful that's
what I do
that's my job your mission
there's something special power with
that one I don't I don't understand
oh it is oh damn
hey friends oh she said hi where are
they oh they're good guys
whoops tag is the best thing ever
last time let's all gather around here
in the center guys great idea now you're
dead though that's that's the catch of
that idea that you had I know I said
what everything worked great fireworks
there we go hello Michigan valleys thank
you very much so happy
hi you wanna go on a date I'll take that
as a yes
you're welcome skins really fun just to
[ __ ] around with all their the neon
lights finally and sanic I love sanic
sanic loves you we both like to shampoo
our whatever you don't know hello
Kamel are you you gotta appreciate how
much the drivers don't give a [ __ ] that
someone is standing on their car while
they're driving
like whatever all right where's the
mission should be down yeah Webster I
can't lever one she said nearby oh cool
found ya now what it's rising watch
Diggs
you know I'm saying we need to find all
the cameras another one damn occurrence
tracking get it because they're wearing
tracksuits sometimes I try to make joke
and then afterwards I cry and hear
something happen you have to follow me
there's a guy with very poor sense of
fashion following me oh my god oh no oh
my god I ran this way she ran into the
alleyway and then she hid there and the
pickings tracksuit guy's like oh yeah
I'm fine you oh no did he fire no I
didn't know they took her
search for clues left behind all right
SMO sis no no problem force Moses I'm
sillas Moses I don't even know how it
works
he dropped its like Hansel and Gretel
she dumped her phone so you want me to
rush in and really brutalize the
tracksuits just point me in the right
direction only Jenny kicks ass give her
a call we gotta leave god I love the
superfast thing is so awesome it freaks
me out every time there doesn't matter
if I actually murdered my knight which
is interesting because that's kind of
the point of the game like do you wanna
murder people or do you want to be a
nice little twang I'm just saying I'm
just saying damn we faced the hammer
fast girl bet you ate the soul of sonic
or sundown [ __ ]
you did you all did you did you think
you don't dead well you did you think
you don't they do they whoa ha sniper uh
what just happened super snipe alright
hi friend you did you you did me you did
make make you dead to me wait oh god
there's so many of them
whoa
Chain Reaction wonderful they all just
died that sniper guy is really not that
good are you there you go that's your
punishment thank you why do I do all
this chip for this guy [ __ ] this guy Oh
jumpin the Chuck got it let's go
coming up my aiming isn't the best in
the world but it's oh it works what how
it's fine look at it what happened it's
like I missed something and it just
blows up oh I didn't see the cars they
made like this stop farming am i doing
three presents from Ecuador all right
got it
whoa way to go
Oh amazing you want to go
no send you oughta send you all that
please you want to go now please I have
my egg no sirs go no they didn't even
fly like the other one come on you have
to fly you have to fly like you want to
come on fly all right what about you you
want to fly you want to fly god damn it
all right there's some people in here
this here there we go
what the hell were you guys doing in
there exactly all right let's just use
the similarity and get rid of them
have fun the best attack ever I swear
the guy is so awesome okay
amazing no no say it after yeah but what
are they doing that's not a mayor
amazing how one right here no what is
Bryce finished answer it Oh you had two
cell phones
whoa the DEP is here [ __ ] ow
hey Nick good I was going home time with
him would set my mind straight
no more panic attacks why I'd have to
crawl inside my memories just to calm
down he was my rock I couldn't wait to
see him uh-oh something bad is gonna
happen here we go put you on the payroll
at least till I get set up around town
then I promise you we'll get him back
can't you just slow down time and I had
to find a memory even a bad one to focus
on to clean too
being homeless it's like you're a human
cockroach the evil looks just never stop
then we got our first taste the
cockroach wasn't so bad
yeah to keep that feeling we'd do
anything rinse all where it was headed
he even hid my stash trying to get me to
kick it with but I was in too deep it
just
good oh damn and in what happened with
your currents out of the way Shane set
his sights on the chief of police hoping
to strong-arm him into some kind of deal
if I helped obediently doing whatever I
was told he promised to let Brett golf I
knew that was a lie with more Dukes
showing up by the hour I needed a plan B
I see that train day that's our only
chance
oh I love this part of Seattle it's so
much cooler to be in because you could
just sand it away faster run faster Oh
help for the love of gal yeah someone
okay we did it you guys didn't see
anything
high-five let me touch your boob it's
okay I'm a girl come on come on don't be
shy
let me touch yours in come on don't be
shy my don't be shy yeah puncture let me
touch it
damnit no friendship allowed all right
Bruce I'm sorry but we have to end this
episode here really fun to play this
game so far I hope you bros are enjoying
it as well thank you for leaving like
always the breakfast what the hell did
happen